viele deutsch lerner verwechseln im
deutschen die drei worte wenn wann und
als wir erklären euch heute den
unterschied zwischen den drei worten und
danach seht ihr noch eine szene in der
wir alle drei worte benutzen los geht's
wann ist ein frage wort und wird nur in
fragen benutzt alle sätze die nach
derzeit fragen benutzen wann wann kommst
du morgen vorbei wann warst du in berlin
wann essen wir endlich als und wenn sind
konjunktionen als ist eine temporale
konjunktion die nur in der vergangenheit
benutzt wird
als ich ein kind war wollte ich gerne
polizistin werden
als ich gestern bei der arbeit war rief
meine mutter an wenn ist eine
konjunktion die temporal und
konditionell benutzt wird das temporale
welt redet über einen zeitpunkt in der
gegenwart oder zukunft wenn wir nach
polen fahren kaufe ich mir eine neue
jacke das konditionelle wenn redet über
eine bedingung die erfüllt wird wenn
morgen die sonne scheint machen wir eine
fahrradtour im englischen kann man alle
drei worte mit den übersetzten das
konditionelle wenn im deutschen kann man
jedoch auch mit if oder im case of
übersetzen
ein häufiger fehler den ich höre wenn
menschen deutsch sprechen vor allem
englischen muttersprache ist so etwas
wie wann ich ein kind war
oder wenn ich ein kind war man
verwechselt also oft die drei
verschiedenen worte jetzt zeigen wir
euch noch eine szene in der alle drei
worte benutzt werden und ihr könnt die
szene ein paar mal wiederholen und
schauen ob ihr die benutzung von den
drei worten verstanden hat los geht's
wann gehen wir endlich zum musikgeschäft
wenn das wetter besser ist das wetter
ist besser
komm wir gehen zum musikgeschäft als ich
ein kind war ist meine mama jede woche
mit mir zum musikgeschäft gegangen
ach wirklich naja fast jede woche
manchmal hat sie gesagt wir gehen erst
wenn du besser der noten hass und hat
das geholfen mit den besten noten ja
total einmal als ich elf war hatte ich
plötzlich 51 in echt und dann sind wir
fünf mal in der woche zum musikgeschäft
gegangen und da habt ihr dann immer was
gekauft nein natürlich nicht wir hatten
ja kein geld kaufen durfte ich nur dann
was wenn ich geburtstag hatte und was
hast du dann zu den geburtstagen
bekommen als ich 13 war habe ich meine
erste platte bekommen als ich dann 14
war habe ich zum ersten mal ein t shirt
mit den bee gees bekommen das war mein
lieblings t shirt das war unser video
zum thema als wenn und wann wir hoffen
dieses kurze video hat euch geholfen den
unterschied zwischen den drei worten zu
verstehen
jetzt könnt ihr dazu noch übungen machen
und zwar wenn ihr ein mitglied von easy
german bei petschel werdet außerdem
könnt ihr uns abonnieren und ihr solltet
unbedingt uns auf instagram und auf
facebook folgen
dort zeigen wir euch immer was wir
gerade so spannendes machen
wir sehen uns nächste woche bis bald
janus com mit
schnell ja nicht